[Music]
a deli penguins near the ross sea
are frequently on the move waddling and
sliding along icy surfaces
not to mention breeding or hunting for
food
their antarctic home can experience
whiteout conditions from snow
and freezing rain and winds upwards of
90 to 100 miles per hour
this leaves drones and helicopters tight
flight windows
to observe penguin colonies from above
new research published in science
robotics
took advantage of this challenge to test
an automated technique
for piloting drones in extreme
environments
its flight path algorithm was shown to
speed up penguin surveys
more than tenfold the algorithm
affectionately dubbed popcorn uses a
mathematical system
to navigate tricky environmental
barriers in ways that human piloted
drones haven't
rather than the zigzagging lawnmower
pattern of individually flown drones
popcorn takes a contoured path over a
targeted area
and layers the paths of multiple drones
this helps preserve battery life
while maintaining survey coverage
the study scientists aim their sites at
cape crosier
one of the largest adelie penguin
colonies in the world
with more than 300 000 nesting pairs
the algorithm set its course by
designing a grid of the target area
and assigning gps coordinates to points
on the grid
satellite elevation data prevented
drones from colliding with each other
in the varying slopes of cape crosier
this data also helped meet strict
regulations on airspace over penguin
colonies
and ensure the safety of the cape's
tuxedo residents
and popcorn fixed the path start and
stop positions in the same place
to simplify the search for a safe
landing site
all of this the researchers claim made
the aerial survey as
easy as pressing a button previously
human piloted drone surveys of this
region took over two
days to complete the new automated drone
network
accomplished the task in three hours
ecologists hope this technique will
provide better estimates of penguin
populations than
individual drones and satellite imagery
and
for the first time allow large aerial
surveys of their chicks
which are currently counted on the
ground beak by beak
adelie penguins also indicate changes in
climate
their hunting movements and breeding
success are smoking guns
for sea ice transformations in raw sea
the research team has already deployed
its technology
to help track bird movements in
california and livestock
on ranches one day
the team envisions popcorn contributing
to wildfire surveys
its swift operations detecting
vulnerable areas of forest
and brush under intense time pressure
as climate change and conservation force
us to rethink the way we see the world
this eye in the sky could prove a handy
and hands-free
[Music]
tool